biden is trying to bypass recent  setbacks by outlining the progress he's  made since he signed the one trillion  dollar infrastructure package  administration officials announcing that  the next funds are on the way to states  in order to clean up abandoned oil wells  a pollutant in the country's air and  water supply  these wells jeopardize public health and  safety by contaminating groundwater  seeping toxic chemicals chemicals  emitting harmful pollutants including  methane  now depending on how quickly states move  other projects funded by the law could  start later this year he does stress the  president's goal is making the right  long-term investment in the country and  our economy